what advice do you have for aspiring
YouTubers that are starting from ground
one expect the suck at the beginning but
Allan wasn't Allan either at the
beginning you know Alan sucked at the
start go watch episode one episode one
is supposed to suck don't take that as
you suck as a human like that's a
problems we make something it sucks we
watch ourselves back on camera like oh
my gosh I was so bad I can't believe it
was that bad no like make another video
another video and another video it took
me 350 videos until I wasn't completely
embarrassed by my stuff like I couldn't
watch it back and 700 videos until I
inspired myself where I watched the
video like you know what like I'm I
might be getting good at this thing huh
700 videos in most people can get there
a lot faster than it took me to get down
that path and we just have these
unrealistic internal expectations for
how good we should be so expect to suck
and then just go create and keep making
content need motivation watch a top 10
with believe Nation hey s Carmichael and
I make these videos because I I need
them for me because I want to wake up
every day and watch a video that puts me
in a mindset to believe in myself more
and go off and accomplish amazing things
and attack the day and I hope that this
video does that for you as well okay so
today let's learn from one of the best
my husband Evan Car Michael and our take
on his top 10 rules for Success
enjoy rule number two invest in yourself
I think one of the biggest mistakes I
made early on when I when had any money
was I just tried to invest it and put
into the stock market and I remember
like I had 2,000 bucks like okay I'm
going to put in the stock market it's
going to grow I like oh it's like taking
so long to grow it's only 2,000 where
Jeremy actually made a much smarter call
like I think at the beginning you invest
in your skills and you invest in your
network because that $2,500 investment
that Jeremy made now has a mid six fig
or high six figure business every year
because he came to that event but if you
put it into the stock market sure would
grow but I think at the beginning you
need to invest in yourself to get the
skills that you need to be able to then
create the network and create value for
other people yeah and and when
entrepreneurs any entrepreneur here
watching you're thinking about starting
your business the easiest way to start
making money is to provide a high value
business or service to people who have
money to pay you and so getting into
YouTube Consulting is great because
there's not a ton of people into it yeah
right hasn't been around for 40 years if
you're going to get into tax accounting
that's a great business to be into but
you have to have years of experience to
know what you're doing right I did um I
did an interview with Tom on his channel
like that guy's an expert he's a genius
he's a genius so if you're gonna go and
compete with Tom it's going to take you
so many years to even catch up to a base
level of knowledge but in YouTube
Consulting it's easier because there is
nobody really who's been doing this for
40 years right or you're a chat GPT
consultant and you're helping use AI for
people in the co who is the expert on
that like there's nobody cuz it's still
so brand new so this is the area where
it's super high value for clients but
there aren't a lot of experts at it so
for you to spend six months becoming
great at it you could be now in the top
1% of all people who know how to use
that thing and then start charging for
your services on top of it rule number
three discover your core value what is
the importance of video influencers
watching maybe thinking about focusing
their branding and their message me yeah
I think if you're a human being you have
a core value there's something inside of
you that is the most important value in
the world something that you place
higher than money and when you figure
out what that is and then you bring that
not just to your business but to your
life the people you hang out with but in
the context of creating a YouTube
channel the content like how do you
stand out if you are another family
vlogger another gamer another
entrepreneur and there's tons of
competition how do you do it it's based
off of what is the single most important
core value that you want people to feel
cuz I want people to feel an emotion
when they watch my videos when they
watch these interviews I want you to
feel an emotion and not just get content
got it so your one word is believe right
it is what's the story behind that how
did you come over that uh it came from
my parents they always taught me that I
was I was Evan cust caricel I could do
anything that I wanted it's a message I
still pass on to my son and they just
made me feel like whatever I wanted to
do it was possible and to believe in
myself to do it and it's it's come
through my entire life my favorite movie
is Sea Biscuit it's about this horse
that is too small and a jockey that's
too big and a owner that had no money
they come together it's this Underdog
Story and so anything around believe
just I feel better about now translate
that to a YouTube world when I had my
channel I saw my channel but like my
first video that took off that did well
was this video took me a year to get to
100,000 views on it and I was like I was
so happy 100,000 views for a lot of you
watching that may be more than what you
have right now I was so pumped I made a
a video around believe which was my one
word and we hit 100,000 views in a month
and that video now has over 2 million
views and now believe oozes out of
everything that I create so I'm trying
to give you the content that you can use
to grow your business but I want you to
feel out of every piece of content that
you can go off and do whatever your main
Big Goal is I want you to feel believe
out of everything that I create rule
number four keep the community engaged
how do you come up with your video ideas
to keep your community engaged
that's a combination of what do I want
to make with what are people asking for
and I think that's set the success of
any any successful business not just a
YouTube channel not just a podcast or a
show it's like what do you love doing
with where is their demand if you take
something that you just love doing but
nobody cares you have a
hobby great could be a really fulfilling
hobby but it's just a hobby and if you
take something that everybody wants but
you don't really care about you're never
going to win because you're you're doing
work that you hate and there's somebody
else out there who loves doing that
thing and so don't spend your time doing
work that you hate so it's in that
combination of like what do I love doing
with what do people actually want that
every business can become successful so
for me um we get a lot of feedback from
the audience people leave comments like
hey I'd love to see a video on blank and
maybe I know how to do that and maybe I
really resonate with that or maybe I
don't and and then we don't um or just
starts with me saying I think this could
be a cool idea and then I try to make
that video and put it out there uh and
sometimes they take off and they do well
and we do a lot more and sometimes it
completely flops it's like okay cool
well nobody liked that move on to the
next idea I think the key though within
all of that is we're not so attached to
this thing having to work a lot of times
people when they're first launching
their YouTube channel their business
their podcast whatever we put so much
pressure on the on the launch being
perfect and then if it doesn't work out
we feel like a failure where for me it's
just okay we're going to try that and
we're going to try try this I'm going to
try that and and something's going to
work and if that that thing yesterday
didn't work cool I've got 18 more ideas
I'm going to try until I find the thing
that does work also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
runy find a mentor I think it's a really
hard road to become an entrepreneur how
did you find your Mentor cuz that's
that's really hard for a lot of people
yeah the trick is when you when you find
somebody who you like
who you think they're ahead of you and
you think they might have something to
contribute like just you have to find a
way to get closer to them so I'll give
you two stories a first with me and
Steve uh I met Steve through one of his
clients so one of his clients was in
Toronto same city as me and we met at a
coffee shop and he had this idea for the
to pitch on a YouTube video and uh he
said that his agent came up with this
idea he's like agent like what do you
mean agent how do you have an agent
you're like a business guy or like a
YouTuber how do you have an agent cuz I
thought agents were only first sports
stars or musicians like how do you like
yeah I have an agent he represents like
thought leaders like ah okay can I can I
meet him and uh so he introduced me to
Steve I hopped on the call Steve made me
feel very uncomfortable you know in all
the in all the right ways yeah um and
and that led to me wanting to do more
with him even though I didn't fit the
typical mold mold so it's it's following
the Curiosity right if I never I met I
met this guy in Toronto his name was
Shawn and if I never asked Sean about
the agent I wouldn't have had that
conversation um fast forward a couple
years ago there was a guy Jeremy who
came to one of my events and he's paid
like 2500 bucks or something to come to
event he's 18 19 years old he is working
as a grocery store clerk okay like hates
his life doesn't want to work grocery
store doesn't know what he really wants
to do likes my energy saw my YouTube
videos come to the event it's three-day
event at the end of the event he
messages me says hey Evan I just want to
how do I spend more time with you I
don't have any skills yet but I'll I'll
walk your dog I'll I'll clean your car
I'll mow your lawn like I just want to
spend more time with you and I messaged
him back said that's super amazing
Jeremy but I don't like I don't need
somebody to walk my dog or clean my car
but um but thank you um a couple months
later I was driving on my tour I'm
driving through this desert in Texas and
I think of Jeremy and I thought huh
maybe I could teach Jeremy YouTube
like I wonder people keep asking me
about YouTube and they want me to do
work on their Channel and I don't I
don't want to do that as a business but
maybe I could teach Jeremy how to do it
and so we got Jeremy on the phone that
moment oh uh he he took a little break
from his grocery store you know job and
said Jeremy I want to teach you YouTube
we'll start a business together and I'm
away for the next two months on the road
so I need you to watch all of these
videos and learn everything you can
about YouTube and when I come back if
you've done that I'll help you build a
YouTube Consulting business wow um and
we did and now he's got uh a high sixf
fig YouTube business uh Consulting he he
made six figures in the first six months
or so of having his business um and
that's from being a grocery store clerk
right but if he didn't do that Outreach
to me I wouldn't have taken a shot on
him either it's just the the heart and
the energy and the care and he's just
I'll wash your car and I'll clean you
know hang out with your dog I just love
the energy and even though nothing came
up in the moment he was in the back of
my mind to say okay maybe I should do
something with Jeremy and so it's it's
trying to be in a room where you get to
talk to them but then it's it's almost
uh uncomfortable like next ask and
showing your hunger and your commitment
level and then the key thing is when you
get that is you ask one question to the
mentor cuz successful people actually
love mentoring
but they also hate wasting time like
time is the most valuable asset and they
love mentoring but they hate wasting
time and a lot of mentees waste time
yeah because they don't do the work so
the best thing you can do if you want if
you're trying to get into a mentorship
relationship you ask one question like
what's the one question you've got to
ask Robert Kaki one question like what's
the one question that you want to ask
him right and then don't ask another
question because that's what people will
do they'll come back and say oh what
about this and what about that it's like
no no no like do the work on the first
question that he gave you an answer for
yeah and then go home and actually do
the work and if you get a result then
you can come back and ask the second
question hey I asked you this I did this
now my I've got five Apartments man
thank you from your advice now I'm
struggling with this he's much more
likely to give you a second answer
because of the work you did on the first
one yeah or if the advice didn't work
make sure that you tried it a hundred
times right it wasn't just you tried you
made one phone call and it didn't work
and so the the advice sucked right cuz
if you tried it a 100 times and you
showed the effort then he's willing to
answer a second question rule number six
be with the right people hav you a brand
new book called momentum I love the word
momentum I think it's the hardest thing
to get and the easiest thing to lose why
the book momentum and why now
brother uh I actually wasn't planning on
writing the book at all built to serve
was my book I was like it's still the
book and then I did a a session with my
now business partner uh Kira and we did
an IG live together and she kind of
pulled it out of me and uh this idea
just came out like momentum that's
that's the book I often tell people the
only thing they're missing is momentum
like you have the heart and you have the
idea and you have the the willingness to
serve and like you're doing it for the
right reasons and you deserve to make
money what's missing just momentum like
you're overthinking you're over you're
over you're over planning you're just
over over and you're not doing enough
like momentum uh and so she challenged
me to write the book in eight weeks my
first book took me a year to write and
then she said well when are you gonna
start and the book's called momentum
right so like when of course I have to
start now like I'm gonna start next week
I'm going to start in a month like no I
have to eat my own dog food and so I
wrote it uh I wrote it like I got off
the call with her at 3M Eastern and just
started writing and I wrote it in five
days it's like this book was written in
five days and we ended up having it
published in eight weeks and so when
you're you're to Dave's point of like
when you're in the right frequency and
around the right people and hitting the
right vibration like you can create
Magic and if you're not it's because
you're in the wrong frequency around the
wrong people and you have the wrong
thinking in your head too rule number
seven stop being a professionist what
system or process do you have are are
used for your filming and editing is
there particular
methodology um I think that's evolved
over the years at the beginning I
probably spent way too much time trying
to figure all the stuff out you know my
first video took me a full day to record
cuz I was trying to it was one video
it's like 6 minutes it took a whole day
to
record cuz I was trying to get it
perfect and the camera and the lighting
and my friend came in who's a
professional videographer and he filmed
me and I had to memorize my script and
uh over the years has gotten a lot more
streamlined and faster and I've cared
less about it being perfect and more
about me just showing up and trying to
connect more to the heart and less to
the head if we had done this interview
even three years ago I would have said
okay I need to know what are Allen's
questions going to be I want to know
what his questions are uh because I
wanted to have an answer because I would
be afraid of I don't want to disappoint
your audience don't want you to ask me
some question I'm like oh my gosh I
don't know but what would end up
happening is I give a really prepared
rehearsed answer which then doesn't
actually bring the most value to your
community and so instead like I don't
want to know the questions I don't want
to know you know what you're going to
ask me let's just go with it and hope
that um I have enough inside me to be
able to share and
so I wish I had done that sooner you
know if you look back I probably
wouldn't have made changes but like if I
could talk to Evan who starting this
Channel at the beginning like don't be
so stressed out about saying the perfect
words and having the perfect lighting
and gear and editing process just go
make create and the more you can connect
in your heart instead of your head and
what you think is perfect the better
results you'll actually have rule number
eight learn to manage your team where do
we learn to manage people you don't
learn that in school right we don't
learn how to manage people we're taught
usually the opposite in school which
Robert loves talking about it's like
it's cheating it's cheating to look at
somebody else's test or work together
right you got to do all by yourself but
like that's the opposite in business you
have to do it as a team so where do we
learn the ability to manage and delegate
we don't right I I think a lot of people
even if you think about school projects
we're usually the ones like hard
carrying the school projects or we're
taught to be like the smartest person in
the room right like you always want to
compete against the person next to you
or Robert teaches us like you don't want
to be the smartest person in the room
you want your team to be the smartest
people in the room it's completely
counter to what we learn in in the
school system so so great you know if
you've never LED somebody before you're
probably not going to be a great boss it
doesn't mean you're going to be a
terrible boss you're going to chew them
out and they're going to hate you but
you need to learn how to actually manage
people and so it's easier to manage
somebody for an hour a day part-time
while you're still running your company
than to have a full-time person who you
now committed to it's very rare that the
first employee at any company is still
there look at employee number one and 10
years later like that person's gone not
because the person sucked it's because
you sucked as
yeah like you don't know how to H you
don't know how toate you don't know how
to manage you how to train we think that
we get somebody in and then oh this
person's going to take off all my
problems you got to you got to train
them you got to Mentor them you got to
help and so it's easier to get started
like that's a skill that you will that
will serve you for the rest of your life
no matter what you end up doing rule
number nine get inspired I'm a big
believer that the ideas that come to you
when you're feeling bold excited
powerful inspired like those are the
right ones for you
and then we spend most of our time
talking ourselves down from like why we
can't do those things so if you if
you're watching a Craig video or a Dave
video you're hanging out and you get
inspired like that idea that's the
that's the that's your best version
talking to you and you owe it to you to
go do something and take the first step
like you get inspired to go start your
own IG live or your own YouTube channel
awesome like just make a video people
get cut up like what camera and what
microphone and what am I going to talk
about and then it's like you're it's
over it's over like just press record
and make your first video that's the
first step and that's like people take a
decade to get to the first step that's
the problem so the ideas accomp when
feeling bold those are the right ones
for you rule number 10 the last one
before some special bonus clip pursue
your passion what are some of your best
tips and practices for entrepreneurs
staying charged staying focused and
growing really in their leadership and
as entrepreneurs so first off I think
you have to be doing something that you
absolutely love if you look at any of
the successful entrepreneurs you look up
to or in any field athletes singers
musicians artists you have to love the
work of what you're doing and not just
try to be YouTube famous if you're
watching this trying to be YouTube
famous it's not going to get you
anywhere you have to love the actual
process of making videos and being able
to influence people yeah editing wise
that you landed that plane yeah love it
okay so what else the other important
thing really is that you need to have a
morning routine that sets you up for
Success so we talked about like what's
one thing that you can't miss you need
to have that can't Miss stuff in your
morning routine to get you charged to
energized because too often what happens
is people get motivated you watch one of
these videos you're not subscribed yet
you haven't hit the Bell so you only one
video you get all pumped and then next
day you wake up and like it's gone yeah
and we all we all have that we don't say
we do but we have it you wake up nobody
wakes up every day like Mega passion to
go and so you need to whatever that is
that gets you excited if it's if it's
watching this guy every day then watch
him every day like you need to put that
your morning routine so that you start
your day feeling energized and bold and
on fire to go do amazing things as
opposed to shrinking down and then
hoping by accident you come across
something that gets you pumped
up stop trying to do this
alone if you've got a big idea inside
you you can't do this alone you need
people around you to help you to
encourage you to support you to cover
your weaknesses to help you actually go
off and accomplish that big dream of
yours this is one of the biggest things
that I think holds people back holds
entrepreneurs
back is you're probably decently good at
the thing that you want to do you know
you've had some experience or you've
gone and learned and figured it out and
you still to get better as you keep
practicing and keep going and doing more
and maybe at some point you even did try
to hire somebody maybe at some point you
did try to bring somebody on and it
didn't work
out didn't work out and here's where
everybody makes the mistake you Retreat
and go back to say you know what it was
just a lot faster when I did it myself
does that happen has that happened to
you you ever been there you hired
somebody you thought I'm going to do
this I'm going to hire somebody you do
it it doesn't work out and then you go
back to say I'm just going to do this
all myself no no no no no no that is not
the answer that is not the answer that's
like if you go on one date and it
doesn't work out now you're never going
to go on another date again again you're
never going to be married right that
doesn't make
sense that doesn't make sense you're
living in fear as opposed to actually
trying to build a thing that you're
capable of building here's what happens
when you first hire somebody you don't
know what you're doing right it's like
when you first did anything you don't
know what you're
doing so why do you expect to be great
at picking the right person and then
treating them well and then managing
them well you don't know what you're
doing uh there's a guy in my mov makers
who who joined my Discord as well and um
he was talking about how he had hired
his second video editor and it didn't
work out and he had to let the person go
so he's hired two video editors both of
them couldn't get his style and he had
to let them go and he's going back to
editing everything himself now as a
short-term solution great like stuff has
to get up videos have to be edited get
them
out but don't stop
searching just because you had two
failed hires right like if you tomorrow
are editing videos awesome but if you
next year are still editing your videos
not awesome nope not awesome not anymore
right this is how we start to raise our
standards and so the first two people
that you hired weren't good fits great
keep searching keep looking your perfect
fit is out there and as you go through
some people and go through the process
you'll get better at actually finding
the right
person you know you'll get better at it
don't judge yourself that say well I
suck at this I can't hire I'm never
going to find the person it's just
faster to do it myself right there's
that old expression you can go fast by
yourself but you go far with a
team you have to build a team you've got
your bis Dev show and the point of bis
Dev show is to bring ideal clients on if
you don't think they're an ideal client
or they could refer ideal clients to you
then they're not on the show I again the
light bu on this morning was
to uh pick entrepreneurs choose
entrepreneurs to come on to
entrepreneurship show and in our mind uh
well in my mind entrepreneurs would
probably watch it because I'm talking to
entrepre entrepreneur so yeah I I'm I I
really my mind is really shifted yeah
but they're coming on and just listen to
somebody else's story that doesn't why I
then hire you I don't know you're just
Larry King asking questions you're a
great question asker right okay well I'm
not hiring you for
that so unless your goal is to be an MC
or to host shows or something else then
then that's a different model right but
if like I'm a coach and I want to sell
more coaching Services then that that's
a better model so you're bringing people
if they don't if they're either not an
ideal client meaning they have a
business and they can can afford your
services like if it's a brand new
startup and they're dead broke it's not
an ideal client because they can't
afford you so ideal clients or referral
Partners lawyers accountants those kinds
of people who deal with entrepreneurs
all day long like if you have the right
lawyer on and they love you they could
be referring every client how you are
like connecting with your followers on a
level um that is adding value to them
but is allowing them to continue to
consume your content why you have to
love it like I love connecting with the
community okay so there's a lot of
people who who don't love it and you
don't have to do it right so I remember
was in New York and was meeting a really
bigname author you know New York Times
bcell Etc and I was in town said hey
let's go grab breakfast so we grabb
breakfast together and he said well what
are you doing for the rest of the day he
like I'm going to have lunch with
another fan who said he like became a
millionaire after watching my content
and then we're going to do an afternoon
meet up at a Starbucks with you know my
fans in New York and we're just going to
chill at the Starbucks and ask questions
I don't care about seeing New York I
just care about meeting the people and
he said that sounds exhausting like oh
what are you going to do he's like I'm
going to go back to my room and write
and he's had tons of success as a writer
right so it's not that one way is better
than the other it's just that I I love
doing it and so tapping into like if
that's where you get your energy from of
the audience that you have and people
listening to you watching you Etc then
that's where the thing needs to be
birthed not from uh this is a good
strategy so I guess I should do it right
so inside of that I do things like that
where I do meetups in cities when I
travel uh even here inviting you back
it's like you message me he like hey
what are you doing on Tuesday you want
to come by and do something you know for
Content too and and every day I'll do
Instagram questions if you see my
stories I always put a question and then
at the end of the night my evening
routine no matter how tired I am I'm
still like responding to questions I'll
do like 10
questions you're responding yourself
yeah it's me like when I'm helping
people I try to do it where there
scalability to it as well okay
so you know the the people who are here
today that I'm helping they're helping
but it's also content so other people
can learn from it hopefully in in your
story right when I'm doing Instagram Q&A
it's on my stories so people can leave a
question I'll answer it for
everybody okay right um I still do a lot
of one-on ones in the DMS as well but
that there's just not enough time in the
day to hit everyone even the questions I
com in every day don't have time to do
everybody but it's more of a heart thing
where it's like I need that as part of
my nightly routine to stay connected to
the
work because otherwise it becomes why am
I doing this stuff you know the numbers
start to blur or not mean much right you
know you had a million or two million or
whatever it's like okay I don't know
what that means but somebody's saying
your video change my life you saying you
know I watched your videos for eight
years every day to learn from somebody
new that that's why I do what I do I
need to feel connected to who I'm
serving or helping okay and in doing
that then it makes me want to show up
more more cuz if you're just making
videos in your office or you're just
recording a song in a studio and you
can't connect to like who it's going to
actually help at least for me it's not
as powerful you become who you
consistently hang around with who you
spend the majority of your time with
both people who you're actually
physically meeting and connecting with
and hanging out with and what you feed
into your brain that's how you start to
think that's how you start to behave
that's how you start to act think about
your mindsets your belief systems it
comes from the people who you're
consistently around so if you want to
change your life you want to change your
direction you're tired of living where
you are you're tired of your situation
right now the fastest way to change it
is to change who you start to associate
with I remember when I first got uh
started on my entrepreneurial career I
always felt like I was kind of a dummy
um I was a slow learner in school I
never got I never I didn't fail out of
class but I never got the Straight A's
you know that my sisters kept getting
and what I realized was I'm not dumb I
just need the right models and the right
mentors I had a different way of
learning than a lot of people and when I
started to figure that out I was like
I'm not I'm not an idiot I'm not dumb I
can do this but I need to be around the
people who are doing it because because
when I can get that mentorship when I
can get that learning style down then I
can do amazing things that's it that's
the only difference the only difference
is I just don't have the right people
around me and I learned that lesson over
and over and over and over again that
when I just try to figure it out myself
I usually don't win when I'm doing a
structured learning style like in a
classroom setting I also usually don't
win but when I can surround myself with
the people who are doing it and get the
the coaching and mentorship and guidance
that I need I can go I can win I can
actually do
stuff big big Revelation I'm not a dummy
like I thought I was growing up uh and
so how do you do it how do you actually
start to be around the people who are
inspiring you lifting you up I'm going
to I'm going to share three strategies
that I think will help okay the first is
actual people in your life so you start
to audit the people in your life how
much are the people in your life
building you up making you believe in
yourself giving you encouragement giving
you support giving you love telling you
that you can do it how many people do
you have like that in your life probably
not a lot most of us probably don't have
that many people and so you want to
immediately cut out the people who uh
are not giving you that hope and
encouragement or at least spending less
time with them because maybe that's your
mom right so spending less time or or
not talking about your career or your
business with the people who don't
support you and then injecting more the
people who do and fighting to find ways
to spend more time with the people who
lift you up who make you feel like
things are possible fighting to spend
more time with them I have an expression
that I use uh where I like to I like to
collect good people I like to collect
good people I like to have people around
me that make me feel great and when find
somebody I fight to try to spend more
time with them whether it's start a
business with them whether that's uh do
a monthly call with them think about
who's made you feel the best who who is
somebody that you know and it probably
isn't your parents or or close family
members there somebody in in the outer
ring of your circle how can you now
regularly spend more time with them an
easy starting point is a monthly coffee
how can you have a monthly coffee with
them to talk about your business ideas
and where you're going so you want to
try to inject more of that positive
postivity uh into your circle into your
group into your life step number two is
the aspirational people that you may
never meet but you can be surrounded by
so if you love Warren Buffett hey maybe
maybe Warren Buffett's not going to sit
down with you for a monthly coffee to
chat about your business and your ideas
but there's his videos there's his books
there's lots of stuff on YouTube you can
start with my channel there's a lot of
content that you can learn if you
watched a warm Buffett video every day
guess what's going to happen you're
going to start to think like him you're
going to start to adopt his mindset his
mentality you're going to you're going
to take on his belief systems a little
bit more and so the more you're around
Warren Buffett the more you're going to
start to process things like him and
think like him and so you may never meet
him for all the people who are watching
say well I don't know anybody who's had
success okay well you don't need to but
you can still learn from the people
who've done it that's the beauty of
YouTube right now that's that's
everything that I've learned I learned I
learned how to get out of the hole I was
in my first business by learning from
Bill Gates I still have never met Bill
Gates but he saved my company because I
learned from his story because I was
willing to at that time read books uh
now I would much prefer to watch videos
and to to read books on the topic but
however you learn videos books podcasts
Your Heroes are making content be around
them more be around them more cuz they
will lift you up they will make you feel
like things are possible when the people
around you are telling you all the
reasons why you're not going to win and
then step number three is is join some
kind of group join some kind of group
some kind of uh Community some kind of
connection where you can be around
like-minded people the one that I use a
lot is my mov makers program so inside
mve makers we meet every two weeks
talking about a different tactic to grow
your movement and also connecting people
together it becomes a family when you're
the only one in your circle doing
something man it's so hard to keep going
to keep the motivation to to be the the
person who's constantly lifting other
people up who's doing that for you so
whether it's movement makers or some
other program get into one where you're
around your peers when you're around
people who are also trying to do big
things when you're around somebody else
who's trying to have a big impact and
change the world and when you're saying
even language like that you know if I'm
talking about I want to build something
to change the world you know most of the
people shopping here at Costco think
when who's this crazy guy you can't do
that right that's most of the people
around us but when you find your tribe a
people people who are also trying to do
something big something scary something
crazy you start to feel like this is
possible finally yes right and so
whether it's Movie Makers or something
else to get a part of a network of
people your peers so in the early the
first two bits of advice you're learning
from people who are who've done more
than you but being just around peers who
are doing the same thing maybe in a
different industry but they're they're
trying to chase down their goals you can
motivate each other so that when you're
feeling down they they give you a little
bit of extra jet fuel and and you do the
same for them you fill them up when they
need it because that little extra bit
can make the difference between you
quitting and you going off and spending
one more day and that one day might be
the difference between you building a
giant company or working at some job
that you hate for the rest of your life
and so your Heroes really matter the
people you surround yourself with really
matters there's only so much you can do
completely by yourself you know the
fastest way to win is to is to model
success and so you can do that you can
do that if you follow those three steps
if you start to weed out the people from
your life who are just filling with
negativity and spend more time with good
people learn to collect good people if
you learn from your aspirational mentors
and you watch their videos make it part
of your daily routine that's why I make
so much content because there's always
somebody you can learn from but there's
no excuse we I don't know how many
videos we do every single day a lot of
different videos every single day
day why because there's no excuse now
for you not to be surrounded by Your
Heroes to learn something from them to
be educated by them to be inspired by
them every single day whether it's my
videos or something else to inject that
as part of your daily routine in the
morning it really really matters and
then three to join a group some kind of
peer group be around people who are
doing things that you can lean on and
ask for their support and that you can
you can support them as well when they
need the help you do those three things
your life will change
influencing someone starts with you
being their chief goal officer that is
your job be their chief goal officer you
have to understand what their values are
you have to understand what their
Ambitions are you have to understand who
they are before you can influence them
the worst advice that you can give
somebody this is this is a challenge a
lot of leaders face when they're
building an organization the worst
advice you can give somebody is what you
would do the worst advice you can give
somebody is what you would do because
they're not you because they have
different values because they have
different Ambitions because they want a
different path than what you've taken
and so if you just say here's what I
would do and then you come off and
feeling like you're a hero and a genius
you've maybe screwed them over and so
you need to start by being a chief goal
officer if people are not listening to
you if people are not following your
orders if people do not respect you is
because you're giving them wrong advice
because you have not done the work to be
their chief goal officer and then help
them accomplish what they want to
accomplish and figure what the best path
for them okay so how do you become
somebody's Che chief goal officer I'm
going to give you three ways to do it
step number one is know their one word
in Credo your one word is your most
important core value the thing that you
stand on and The Credo are the three
things that make up that Define what
that one word is for people when I first
wrote the book your one word I didn't
anticipate it being a leadership book I
thought it'd be just something that you
use for yourself but it's shocking how
many people now buy the book and give it
to their team so you get a window of
what your team's core values are so you
know how to move and Inspire them as an
example if their one word if somebody in
your team's one word is freedom then it
gives you a window of how to handle that
person they don't want to be
micromanaged they don't want to be told
what to do 24/7 they need to have some
freedom in their decision making and
control so they can go off and do their
job so they they can express themselves
so that they can have fun and be happy
the more you are handcuffing them the
more they feel like you're putting them
in jail the more you're going to lose
and you're not going to influence them
so step number one is figure out for
everyone on your team what are their one
words and credos step number two is what
are their Ambitions what do they want
what do they want to accomplish are they
trying to make a lot of money are they
trying to move to another country are
they trying to learn some certain skills
like what do they want what are they
here for what are they trying to get
because yes they're here to do a job yes
you want them to figure out how to do
XYZ cuz you have a business Target and
you're trying to accomplish that thing
awesome they're a human being they're
not a robot they're not a monkey they're
not just typing things in for you so you
can accomplish your goals you have your
goals and they have their own set of
goals and if you are not being their
chief goal officer if you do not
understand what their Ambitions are then
you're going to lose then you're going
to give them tasks that they don't want
to do anymore that they're going to grow
and learn and want to expand and you
don't know how they want to expand and
they're going to quit and they're going
to leave you and you're not going to be
able to push them forward you have to do
the job of figuring out how if they want
to go here this is their ambition and
they're here right now you have to make
that path visible you have to show them
how they can go from here to here and
then you put everything that they're
doing in that light so this is the path
I want you to get here too I know you
want to be here I want you to get here
here's how to get there and they may not
see it because they haven't experienced
it yet they may not be able to tie the
dots together to say oh if I do this
I'll be able to get there that's your
job help them be their chief goal
officer understand their Ambitions step
number two and then step number three is
how can you run parallel paths together
so it's pretty unlikely that somebody on
your team will stay with you forever
they have Ambitions they have goals they
want to get somewhere and if you
understand what their goals are and you
know where you want to go then great
you're running this parallel path
together and that parallel path might be
for 3 months it might be for a year it
might be for 6 years or it might be
forever but at some point they want to
go off and do something else you're a
stepping stone for them to get somewhere
else and that's awesome you should
celebrate that don't fear that celebrate
that and then figure out how you can be
a part of their success how you can run
that parallel path together and then
when they're ready push them away like
you're ready you should go off and do
that thing now go do that thing you're
ready you should be with me anymore
figure out how you can run the parallel
paths together and then help them go and
be the person that they want to be once
they've hit the end of the road with you
so that's a three-step process to being
someone's chief goal officer one figure
out what their one word and Credo are
two figure out what their Ambitions are
and then three figure out how can you
run parallel paths together with YouTube
I feel like this is my moment I feel
like I know what I'm doing I feel like I
have my window however long it's going
to last it could be 6 months 12 months
24 months I got to push as hard as I can
I feel like we're really hitting it I
think it's a great combination of
everything that I love doing my skill
sets my interest my passion right now to
provide value to myself and to you guys
and so it's why I'm pushing hard I'm
making three videos a
day I go to my
website I had a shift where I said you
know what I want to solve the world's
biggest problem unta human potential
what does that look like I don't know
when I first launched it I had no idea I
deleted my entire website threw up one
picture and that was my homepage if you
go right now you'll see it's still a
bunch of pictures I add a little bit
more meat to the bones but I still don't
know where it's going I don't have all
the answers around it I'm still trying
to figure it out but I figure it out by
doing by testing by having conversations
and so from a SEO perspective my website
sucks but I wasn't interested in the
direction I was going anymore I switched
and so I had to find a way to get
started and so I did it
myself my website has now what I call
the circle potential and all those
points you can click on it and dive a
little bit deeper somebody made a
comment when he clicked on the first
version of my self-awareness button he
said well it's only promoting your stuff
it should have a a wider range you're
right I don't have the answer yet I'm
figuring it
out and so I don't let the fear of
making mistakes prevent me from doing
anything because if I waited until I had
the whole thing figured out what the
perfect website would look like I'd
never lach it and having a website
that's not
complete and building some momentum with
it drives me to want to do more on it
drives me want to figure out more
details on it and so some pages are more
worked out than others but all of them
need a lot more work and it just came
from that initial idea that initial
thesis that as soon as you have an idea
for something you find immediate ways to
take action on it because the momentum
is so so so so so so important the
biggest risk of all is not taking any
risk at all every day there's a battle
raging inside you the battle is between
the Comfort version of yourself and the
growth version of yourself the comfort
you wants to be comfortable doesn't want
to push wants to stay where you are it's
it's difficult it's scary out there
let's stay warm and comfortable and the
growth version of you wants to grow
wants to learn wants to develop wants to
progress wants to serve wants to help
and doing that requires having courage
boldness and jumping into the unknown
and it's a daily battle it's a daily
battle that never goes away and you have
to choose who consistently is going to
win and those daily battles are not won
by doing the big heroic once a year
things it's won by doing the daily
things the daily small things that shift
your identity forward to teach yourself
that you're the growth kind of person
and not the Comfort kind of person the
first time I met Brendan bashard was at
his event at grow grow.com I was
speaking in Phoenix it was his event I
was one of two guest speakers it was him
and his partner speaking and then me and
Eric Thomas and his business partner
invited me to come and speak and flew me
down there and I'd never met Brendan
before I knew uh I knew of him obviously
uh but I didn't never met him face to
face and when I when I met him he came
backstage uh I think it was a day before
I was going to go speak and I met him
backstage and he said hey I can't I
can't wait to to to see you on stage uh
I almost never bring on guest speakers
who I haven't seen speak before but you
came highly recommended by my business
partner so let's do this and I'm going
to watch your speech
and see what you do uh I have a TV
interview that I'm doing and I'm going
to pause that and make sure I'm done so
I can watch your speech so in my head
there's a lot of stress and pressure one
I never met Brendon before two there's a
couple thousand people out there in the
audience uh and three
usually when speakers are on stage the
other speakers aren't super paying
attention you know they're backstage in
their own world doing their own thing
but Brendon was going to end his
interview to make sure that he was going
to watch my speech and so he's adding
all this extra pressure on me this is
the Battle of of growth versus comfort
of growth Evan versus Comfort Evan my
biggest fear disappointing people I
don't want to disappoint him I don't
want to disappoint the person who who
paid me to be there I don't want to
disappoint the couple thousand people in
the audience
and so we go through these
moments where the comfort you takes over
the comfort you wants to play small
wants to quit wants to back down wants
to find an out wants to find an excuse
for why you can't do something and the
growth you is struggling for control
there's two things that I do that help
growth EV come out and I want you to
internalize them to apply them to use
them because if you can use these two
strategies it can massively shift your
identity forward help you become the
growth version of you instead of the
Comfort version of you and start giving
you the results you want as well as a
more purposeful happy life of service
two things first one take on the
identity that you do difficult
things you do difficult things that if
something is scary or difficult or hard
that it's not a good enough reason that
you do scary you do difficult you love
hard and so I use those as triggers and
why it's important is you shortcut the
thinking pattern every time that you say
that it's scary that it's difficult that
it's hard or whatever words that you use
that give yourself a break that let
yourself off the hook use those as
trigger words that the fact that you
said it means you have to do it the fact
that you said it you thought it you
wrote it means you have to do it just
because what it does is it shortcuts the
excuse because what normally happens is
you say well that's that's too difficult
you've accepted that difficult is a good
enough reason for you to play small you
don't go and do the thing you've
accepted than the excuses that come into
your head of why you can't do it they're
not you don't call them excuses you call
them you call them reasons right logical
valid reasons why you can't do it I want
to shortcut all that I don't want to
even allow you to go there cuz I don't
allow myself to go there the fact that I
said scary difficult hards mean I have
to do it so find your trigger words you
can use mine as a starting point if you
want but find your trigger words and
that becomes your new identity you want
to take on the identity that you do
difficult things that you you jump into
the unknown that those are no longer
good enough reasons for you and so I did
this when I was backstage when I'm my
heart's beating uh I'm I'm I forgot what
I was going to say going on stage like
in the moments leading up to going on
stage I forgot what I was going to say I
have no slides either on stage right I
don't go with a PowerPoint presentation
there's one slide that just has my my
name and face on it that's it no slides
is if I forget what I'm going to say
kind of
screwed so breathe I Evan carmichel does
difficult things I do difficult things
right you remind yourself what that does
is put you into a more resourceful state
to go and actually solve the problem so
that's step one you do difficult things
and and again it's not just the big hero
moments it's the micro there difficult
things that have happened already today
that you have not done what you need to
do cuz it was difficult and you give
yourself it out go do it but that do for
your self- love for your self- pride for
your self resect for your
self-confidence is incredible and and
you need to give yourself that gift I
want you to give yourself that gift
every day of doing the difficult thing
and for you something that's difficult
may seem trivial or small for somebody
else when I broke my neck and and and
was struggling with a concussion getting
out of bed was difficult just getting
out of bed and putting my feet on the
ground and standing up was incredible
pain through my spine incredible pain
which is something I take for granted
now but that was difficult and so when
when those things happen you pat
yourself on the back you did it you did
the difficult thing so that's step
number one you do difficult things the
second mindset shift is leaning into
service it's not even about you news
flash it's not about
you you're here to serve you're here to
help you're you're for all the Ambitions
that you have for yourself whatever the
thing is that you're afraid to do you
the thing we're afraid to do is in front
of somebody else you're not afraid of
failing you're afraid of failing and
who's going to see you
fail right you will sing in the shower
but you won't sing on the street corner
why people will film videos at in in
home at their home but not film it on
the street where people can see them
because you're afraid of being
watched you're not afraid of failing
you're afraid of failing in front of
other people you need to stop being
selfish get out of your own head and
recognize
that you're here to serve you're here to
help you've got a message knowledge
information that can help people and by
you playing small you're doing a
disservice to them and to
yourself and so that's the other thing
that I'll lean into is yeah Evan Carle
does difficult things but also I'm here
to serve and so when I'm backstage and
I'm I know brendon's going to watch me I
know thousands of people are watching me
and I'm afraid of disappointing
everybody I look out into the audience
and instead of seen 2,000 people who are
here to judge me and I'm going to
disappoint them I'm here looking at them
saying I have a message that can help
them I'm here to serve them because what
I'm going to
share Brendan doesn't know Eric Thomas
doesn't know the other speakers here his
Partners they don't know I can share
something unique that can help them and
my my intention is good I'm here to help
these people not rip them off not lead
them down a dark path I'm here to help
them and that again shifts how you feel
about yourself to give you the Courage
the boldness the motivation the power to
go and then do the thing that the growth
version of you needs that's how you get
out of the comfort zone that's how you
get out of comfort you scared you small
you into powerful you bold you
courageous you growth you number one you
do difficult things anytime you find
yourself complaining scary difficult
hard negative you do difficult things
and number two you're here to serve
you're here to serve you're here to help
you're trying to do good and keeping
your gifts to yourself is selfish and
you have to share it and get it out
there those two things on a daily basis
on a daily basis every single day that's
that battle raging inside your head
between the growth you and the comfort
you and my ambition my intention my goal
for you is to have growth you win a
little bit more than comfort you it's
not going to be 100% % growth you
there's no way that's going to happen
don't make that Perfection the bar it's
that every day growth you wins at least
51% of the battles versus comfort you
you do that your life will change the
language you use about yourself when
you're by yourself is what will make or
break your
self-esteem when we talk to other people
when we post on Instagram when we share
our lives we always wanted to to look
good and be amazing and be so positive
right most people's Instagram stories
are are just all of these amazing
highlights and how beautiful my perfect
life is and then you go home when you're
by yourself and you look at yourself in
the mirror and people you know cry
themselves
asleep what's the message when you talk
to yourself what's the message when
you're
alone what are you saying about yourself
when you can start to fix that selft
talk that inner dialogue that starts a
shift everything inside you to then
create amazing things outside
you I remember when I first got started
making YouTube videos my self talk was
uh in Conflict cuz I had my parents who
I remembered the voice you know there's
a picture of my parents behind me on my
wall in my office
and when people ask me what's my
favorite quote of all time it's it's
what my parents used to tell me that I'm
Evan cly carmichel I could do anything
that I believe that I can and that is a
constant reminder that I still today you
know at 41 still use still tell myself
still remind myself of like I am EV G
caricel I can do anything that I believe
that I
can and it's helpful and valuable and
what a gift um so grateful for my
parents for that when I was getting
started on YouTube though the other
voice that was in my head
was you're introverted you're shy you
suck on camera
um anybody who makes videos has a big
ego just needs to be
famous and so I really struggled with
that because I had competing voices in
my head it wasn't even what other people
were telling me to do it was me myself
when I'm by myself thinking about myself
that constant inner struggle with the
voices in my head left me struggling
left me making super slow progress left
me start it and stop it and start it and
stop and if you look at my videos I
started and then I took big breaks and
then I started again then I took more
big breaks and it wasn't until I solved
that inner conflict that I started to
get more results and I started to be
more uh productive and I started to stop
stopping I started to stop stopping I
stopped procrastinating I just did it
because I wasn't so cut up in my head
and the discussion and the in the
dialogue and the voices and I just
replaced it with better thinking about
myself myself better messages to
myself I think when you can do that your
life starts to change because it's not
other people's opinions that we that
really shape us it's other people's
opinions that then influence our own
selft talk that then that's what shape
us what do I do with my life one of the
most important questions that I get
asked over and over and over and over
again people are struggling with what do
I do with my life you see your parents
doing something you see your friends
doing something you know that that's not
the life that you want but you're afraid
of actually chasing down your dreams you
see people living their life on
Instagram and it's so beautiful and
perfect and you're worried that you're
not going to measure up that you're not
going to live up to it that if you try
and do your thing you're going to fail
and so you're constantly stuck in this
what do I do with my life pull between
the safe life that everybody around you
is living and they want you to live for
yourself or the dream life that you know
you're capable of but you don't know
quite what it looks like what do I do
with my life here's what I found you're
going to have moments in your life where
you have absolute
Clarity and equally you'll have moments
in your life where you have zero clue
what to
do let's break those two down when you
have absolute Clarity when you know
exactly what you want to do when it
feels right when you have momentum the
best thing you can do is put your
blinders on and go to work the best
thing you can do is shut down everything
else and get to work building your dream
we often hedge we often play small we
often don't put as much in because we're
afraid but when you have those moments
of clarity you have to go play a bigger
game you have to start betting on
yourself right now I look at my YouTube
channels as an
example this is a pretty special moment
in time
and things are very well aligned for me
right now I mean been doing YouTube for
12 years built up a lot of traction have
a lot of momentum been helping a lot of
my friends made a lot of new friends as
a result of the channel got into rooms
that otherwise I shouldn't be in because
of the success of my channels and it's
been a lot of work and the early years
did not pay off very well at all I share
on my Instagram a lot of my traction and
you know first 5 years the channel we
didn't even have 10,000 subscribers in
the first 5 years and then we went and
hit you know next 5 years 2 million
subscribers now passing 3 million
subscribers on the main Channel but a
lot of a lot of slow slow slow growth
but right now is a very special moment
in time right now I need to push harder
on the YouTube channels right now we've
launched I don't know how many channels
a lot of channels we got a dozen
channels plus maybe at this point I need
to be pushing more on YouTube this is a
moment in time this is the window here
is so wide open that I need to jump
through it because at some point it will
close and and I don't want to look back
on this moment and say I wish I pushed
harder I wish I wasn't afraid I wish I I
did the thing that I knew was right and
we'll have it you'll have those moments
too in your life where you just see it
so clearly you you have this Vision you
you see it all working out but you're
afraid to go actually take the action
you're afraid to go all in on it you're
afraid to do what is necessary and then
what ends up happening is Regret because
you'll be at the end of your life or
even 10 years later thinking I I knew it
I saw it so clearly there was this
opportunity in front of me and I wanted
to do it and I love to do it but I was
too afraid and somebody went else
somebody else went off and made millions
of dollars off of my idea does that ever
happened to you somebody made Millions
off of my
idea no they just went and took action
when you were sitting being afraid and
so when you you have those moments of
clarity you have to push everything else
aside and go after that thing even
though it's scary even though it's too
big even though it feels Beyond you you
have to go after that thing because
that's where your Genius
lies and you either lean into your
Genius and go change the world or you
live the rest of your life with regret
you have to force it you did not ask for
this painful situation you're going
through right now you did not ask for
this health issue for this work issue
for this environmental issue you didn't
ask for this sing to happen to you this
is where we struggle because you didn't
cause this it's probably not your fault
right maybe it is your fault but it's
probably not your fault this thing
that's happened there's a lot that
happened to make this thing happen for
you right now and so it's so easy to get
stuck in the land of negativity why me
wo is me why did this happen as opposed
to flipping to say it's the best this
thing that's happening to me right now
it's the best when I broke my neck I was
on my tour I broke my neck what I said
was it's the best it's the best is it
actually good to break my neck probably
not but it's it's my chance to show
myself what I'm capable of I remember
being woken up so I I passed out I had a
a a concussion I I fell on the floor I
woke up like I fainted I woke up and I
remember the the hospital uh had sent uh
their their ambulance and also fire
people showed up and my circulation was
getting shut off I couldn't feel my arms
I couldn't feel my legs they're worried
that I'm having a heart attack and I
remember going through this in my head
as I'm explaining what's going on they
asked me if I was okay and I said I feel
okay but then I I can't feel my arm I
can't feel my my right arm I can't feel
my legs I can't feel and most people
would be kind of freaking out at this
point oh my God I can't feel my arm I
can't feel my legs and I'm calmly
explaining that oh I can't feel my left
hand right now I can't feel my right
hand right now and and just walking them
through what's going on and in my head
this is why it's so important whether
this is actually true or not in my head
what I'm telling myself is this is the
best I am the greatest patient of all
time as people are normally freaking out
in this moment I'm calm I'm explaining
what's going on I'm I'm amazing right
and I would never say that stuff out
loud but that's what the voice is inside
my head that this is the best this is me
I'm amazing let's go let's solve this
problem and what it does is when when
you're in that negative situation it
switches you to a place of possibility
if you are stuck in complaining and why
everything is so bad and why is this
happening to me all you're doing is
perpetuating the negative situation
you're not actually solving anything
when you can flip it to say this is the
best this is my chance to learn to grow
to improve to solve this to show myself
what I'm capable of what it does is it
puts you in a place of
resourcefulness it takes you from a
place of helplessness into to want of
resourcefulness that then allows you to
go off and solve the problem that
immediate thing that nobody asked for
that you would never wish upon your
worst enemy that's happened to you right
now it gives you the tools to actually
come out of it and so switching your
mindset telling yourself that it's the
best when you've got these moments of
pain and struggle and suffering where
you just want to blame the world and
complain and and tell everybody how
negative it is you flip it it's the best
practice those three words maybe you're
facing that situation right now maybe
you're dealing with something you hate
right now or something if if it's not
right now listen I promise you something
is coming at some point that negativity
is coming for you and so use that as
inspiration it's the best you are where
you are because of you because of the
choices you've made you are right now
here stuck where you're stuck it's not
the government's fault it's not the
economy's fault it's not the algorithm's
fault it's not your parents' fault it's
not even your fault I'm not even here
talking about placing blame it's not
about who we're going to blame it's
about taking the responsibility to fix
it to say I don't want to stay stuck
here where I am right now things have to
change this is not this is not my final
destination I'm going places you're
going places and taking the
responsibility to make that change
happen where too many people just get
stuck up on the blame like while I'm
here because well because of the economy
or because of the president or because
my parents or because my education or
because whatever circumstances and we
use that as a valid excuse a reason for
why we won't take action well it's not
your fault and because it's not your
fault we have somebody to blame and so
that means we can just stay
stuck and unfortunately that's where
most people are stuck they're stuck
being stuck they're stuck placing blame
they're stuck because it's easy because
it's easier to just shut up the world
and go dive into Netflix and entertain
yourself as opposed to actually fixing a
problem when there are problems that
show up in life and that's going to
happen for everybody the most common
responses people have are one to blame
somebody else cuz it's not your fault
and two to go dive into entertainment as
opposed to saying I don't even care
whose fault it is but I'm going to take
responsibility for where I'm at and I'm
going to invest in myself to flip from
entertainment to education so that
changes can start to happen because
until you break that Loop until you
break that cycle you stay stuck and and
it it's comfortable it's comfortable and
and it feels good to know that it's not
our fault but ultimately you're not
happy the short term you're happy
because you can just put the blame on
somebody else but long term you're not
happy you're not happy because you never
get the growth you never get the
progress you never get your goals you
never accomplish your dreams and you're
you're stuck there knowing that you're
capable of more I went through this very
recently on my YouTube channel so um one
of the strategies that I've been helping
some of my friends with there's one guy
in particular who has blown up blown up
on YouTube thanks to one key strategy
that I gave him and I told this to him
maybe a year and a half ago and he
started applying it maybe 6 months ago
and you see Channel popping off growing
faster than I'm growing off of my
strategy and I finally came to the
realization like why am I not doing this
for my own channels I'm telling other
people to do it most people never take
action but this guy actually took action
on it and he's he's crushing me now
doing this stuff why are we not
listening to our own advice like why am
I not doing the same thing on my channel
yet and it came down to while I'm
worried about I'm worried about my team
I'm worried about how much extra work it
is I'm worried about um you know mostly
about my team and like how we've done
things in the past and changing things
up and I finally came to the realization
that no things this has to change
because if it if if I can't make this
work then it's my fault this is my fault
and my team's livelihood is my
responsibility and I need to be
constantly growing and getting better
and if YouTube's algorithm changes I
need to be on top of it and I I need to
be guiding my team in the right
Direction because they rely on me for
their career and for their impact now
could they go get another job of course
but hopefully they like working with me
and the work that we're doing and feel
like they're they're valued and and what
they're creating is having an impact and
so me being
afraid is not a good enough reason and
so it wasn't until I really own that to
say this is you know this maybe took a
couple months for me for really to sink
in like my own advice is being used for
somebody to help them blow up and we're
not doing it because I'm afraid of the
impact that it's going to have on my
team and that can't be a good enough
reason that can't be a good enough
reason because ultimately I'm doing a
disservice to my team I'm doing a
disservice to myself and I'm doing a
disservice to you because the more
people who can see these videos the more
more belief we spread in the world the
more impact we have the more people's
lives change the more great companies
are built this is my mission and so if I
don't do it then it's my fault it's not
YouTube for changing it's not it's not
anybody on my team for resisting it's me
it's my fault and so when when I finally
accepted that then you can move fast
then I messaged some of the key people
on my team and said okay here's here's
what we need to start to do and I
understand there are problems with this
so let's let's fix the problems cuz this
has to happen and now we're doing it and
now we're moving quickly and and and you
know hopefully we'll start to see the
results uh but it wasn't until I
accepted the responsibility for it to
say I'm not going to stay stuck in this
rut that we're in that things start to
change humans are built to serve it's my
new book built to serve if you're not
happy it's because you're not serving
either serving the world or serving the
the closest people to you but if you're
not happy it's cuz you're not serving
and so I want to help other people who
are struggling with belief like I was
and still do believe in themselves more
and me playing small and not doing
videos not speaking on stage doesn't
serve anybody it's selfish it's selfish
for me not to get up and do it so every
time I get on a camera before I do
interviews or when I do stage work or
when I'm making my videos even though
I've done 6,000 videos from my YouTube
channel wow I still get a little nervous
inside before making the videos because
my biggest fear is disappointing people
my biggest fear is I'm going to show up
and not bring value and people are going
to be disappointed in what I made but
that's not a good enough reason I'm here
to serve and so is everybody else and
being afraid is not a good enough reason
not to act when you look at yourself in
the mirror what do you say when you
think about yourself what do you say a
lot of a lot of the stuff that we say
about ourselves we wouldn't we wouldn't
say to our worst enemies it's rough I
actually think it's great to be your own
worst critic I think it's great I think
honestly I think for a lot of people um
we're not hard enough on ourselves let
me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is we don't love ourselves
enough we're not our biggest cheerleader
enough you have to balance those two
things we are very hard on ourselves but
because there's no self-love we're not
cheering ourselves on and if we're not
our biggest
cheerleader you can't handle it most
people are already at the breaking point
you know like sitting here in a parking
lot these you know those I guess it's
kind of blurry you can't really see them
but people hate their lives they're
barely hanging on most people are barely
hanging on we're barely hanging on to
what we're doing we we can post all
these great things on Instagram or
wherever and make a look like we're
enjoying our life but most people are
barely hanging on the people who are
judging you for your life and telling
you that you suck hate their own lives
they are barely hanging on so how do we
get through it well yes we can be harder
on ourselves but we need to balance that
with more
self-love you have to remind yourself of
why you're great what you're proud of
what you're grateful for and it has to
be consistent otherwise you'll never get
to where you want to go and when you
love yourself more that actually allows
you to be harder on
yourself when you love yourself more and
you actually feel it you can push
yourself harder you can you can be more
um demanding of yourself because it's
not going to push you over the edge
because you're not tying your self worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you you don't accomplish it you feel
like a
loser it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing that allows you to be way harder
on
yourself because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
if you want to watch Brendon bashar's
top 10 roots for Success check out the
video next to me I think you're going to
enjoy continue to believe I will see you
there but high performance requires
deliberate habits a deliberate habit
means you kind of have to force yourself
to do it it's not easy it's not
automatic it's not tiny it's like going
the extra mile thing it's the tough work
of life to go to another level you want
to be the top